[Music]
in blotter town in the heart of the
black forest lies an isolated farm here
crops grow cows roam and classic British
cars are serviced like this
austin-healey worth some 80,000 euros
Hoover poise runs a garage for Old
English cars here the English if they
put a screw in there it'll fit no one
else can do it like they can the chrome
they know just where to put it
that's typically British this was an
expensive sports car in its day a luxury
car to pick up your princess so you'll
go out for an ice-cream okay princess
and I'll put on ice it isn't fun
but even without a princess on board
it's still great fun to go out for a
spin in this 1960s dream car and fly by
the hospital scene in the popular German
TV series the Black Forest Glen a Hoover
poised would always choose an old car
over a modern one even if the engine
protests a bit on the steep hills
they'll Road the car the sound it's a
party it's got nothing to do with modern
technology or computer chips
it's really old-fashioned craftsmanship
even driving a takes skill and the
manual labor altogether it's something
you have to feel it also takes a feel
for old British technology to keep cars
like this in working order original
spare parts are hard to come by so a
part can't be restored the replica has
to be made and even making smaller
repairs can sometimes take weeks
take just one screw it's so rusty you
can't move it I spend a whole day fixing
these old cars if the crankshaft is
rusted somewhere you have to take out
the entire engine because you can't get
to it otherwise so there's always this
tension will it work can I get at his
regular customers appreciate Hoover
poises care and expertise old car buffs
won't entrust their baby to just anybody
he really loves old cars I've gotta tell
you when he does something he does it
properly and well I've gotta praise him
be up dish and I'll keep coming back
I'm glad you might be at the coal mine
[Music]
Hoover poise comes from Berlin in the
days of communist East Germany he
learned about cars by turning his Travie
after the Berlin Wall fell Weiss began
working in the Black Forest for a garage
that repaired old cars two years ago he
started his own business for me velvet
central know-how the opening a garage
for classic cars and a big hangar didn't
appeal to me it didn't fit having
different workshops and then a
rolls-royce or a Jag sitting in the
middle old cars require a different
environment and I found it here
[Music]
and this 1970s Triumph Spitfire looks
perfectly at home here in the Black
Forest
[Music]
getting to drive an old classic car like
this through an area like this it's just
out of this world it's like going back
20 years to a time when cars like this
still ruled the roads that's how it
fields then you get out and think what a
shame that that time is gone we're back
to the present hair it really does seem
as if time has Stood Still
at this isolated farm in the heart of
the Black Forest
[Music]
you